let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 I want to hear what's on people's
minds let's go first to our caller from
the 602 area code caller from 602 who's
this where you're calling from ok great
what's on your mind
yes I got so it just this morning of you
know it's working and I'm listening to
Peter Joseph's and he had this whole
like an hour-long video where he was
kind of reaction video to a Jordan
Peterson Tom you know that that whole
debate or discussion that Peterson I
think it's pronounced yes I don't know
how to say it ok so those two had a
discussion and then Peter Joseph had a
reaction video to Peterson I found it to
be you know very interesting I'm sorry
I'm not that prepared Peter Joseph John
Peter Joseph's been on the program a
couple of times and I think he's a smart
guy he's an interesting guy sometimes I
wonder if he would get more attention if
he presented his ideas in a way that was
a little more accessible it's not a
critique of his ideas per se we could
debate any particular idea of Peter
Joseph's but I think that there's a the
opportunity that he could be
significantly more influential and have
more people listening to him if he was
able to kind of tailor his presentation
in a way to have a little broader appeal
I'm not suggesting he appealed to the
lowest common denominator just sort of a
practical question but I have not seen
his video about the Peterson Dziedzic
debate and I saw only about a half
of that debate but I do plan to watch it
this weekend oh cool all right thank you
very much for the call appreciate
hearing from you